hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ist es ja schon bei uns
liegt heute ganz viel liebe in der luft
denn ich werde heute eine richtig
leckere und vor allen dingen hübsche
torte für den valentinstag backen
obwohl wir zu hause keinen valentinstag
feiern den mord und nicht beleben uns
natürlich das ganze jahr über der frauen
kein feiertag dafür aber trotzdem finde
ich es immer schön wenn man trotzdem was
schönes dafür packt vor allen dingen
finde ich kann mir nicht nur seinen oder
seine liebste beschenken sondern einfach
jeden dem einfach lieb haben und das
finde ich einfach immer schön weil
manchmal braucht man einfach ein anlass
dazu und das dann doch jemandem zu
zeigen denn oftmals jetzt im alltag
einfach vergessen
und deswegen gibt es heute leckere rosen
torte und ich wette es jetzt aus einem
leckeren biskuitteig oder besser gesagt
aus lawine masse machen und dafür zeige
ich euch jetzt einfach mal die zutaten
ich brauche dafür sechs eier 200 gramm
zucker eine prise salz
ich nehme vanilleschoten extrakt
vanillezucker geht aber auch aber das
schmeckt natürlich intensiver 180 km 60
gramm speisestärke und einen teelöffel
backpulver und ich habe hier 60 gramm
zerlassene butter und ich werde jetzt
damit starten die eier und die zucker
also den aktiven den circa aufzuschlagen
und zwar markenschutz in der
küchenmaschine
da empfehle ich euch auch sehr dass ihr
eine küchenmaschine dafür benutzt oder
einfach ein handrührgerät dem
handrührgerät dauert natürlich etwas
länger aber die zuckermasse muss jetzt
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten lang
aufgeschlagen werden bis sie einfach
fast schon wieder steif ist
es geht einfach mit einem mit einer
küchenmaschine fiel einfach haben das
ist einfach während im rühren den zucker
einrieseln und stellt auf höchste stufe
und lass es dann eben wie gesagt zehn
befinden lang verrühren ist die eier
masse schön weit bringen
ich nutze jetzt die zwischenzeit um eine
backform vorzubereiten und verwackelt es
heute in einer schönen herz backform ich
habe den bug rahmen und den muss ich
jetzt kurz mit etwas wasser ausbreiten
damit der teig nicht raus läuft und
damit der teig einfach so ein bisschen
besser aufgeht und jetzt nehme ich bin
einfach mein back drin spray oder ihr
nehmt einfach wasser und ich besprüht
diese backformen damit damit er ein
verzeichnis backpapier dran kleben
bleiben kann
deswegen können da auch gern was dann
habe ich hier ein backpapier und das
drittel ich jetzt
damit ich das einfach gleich im streifen
schneiden und die backform auslegen
einfach so
und dann schneide ich das mit einem
messer durch
und bei hunden backformen ist es ja so
da kann man einfach das backpapier unter
die den bug rahmen legen und dann außen
rum einfach zu klappen geht natürlich
bei der herzform nicht weil sehr ecken
und kanten hat und deswegen machen wir
das jetzt hier mit der back streifen
methode jetzt falls ich hier unten so
etwa eineinhalb zentimeter das
backpapier entlang glaube jetzt einfach
alle drei übereinander legen dann geht
es schneller
und jetzt nämlich eine schere und
schneit einfach hier das backpapier ein
um im abstand 15 cm ungefähr muss auch
noch genau sein
da kann ich jetzt den das backpapier
nehmen ist knackig ist hier um sei es
egal wie weit dieses hoch geht einfach
damit es hier oben jetzt sauber hinlegen
kann also hier in die ecke
und dann am rand entlang einen finger
streichen
dann nehmen wir das nächste muss ich
auch einmal umknicken
dann hier rein
schütz ein bisschen knifflig aber es
lohnt sich
so meinen dritten streifen brauchen
ständig den kann ich aufheben und
nächstes mal benutzen
und jetzt muss ich noch aus dem rest
also aus so einem zweiten backpapier
noch diese herzform ausschneiden
ziel ist natürlich vorhanden können
bevor ich die backform damit ausgelegt
habe aber das geht jetzt auch so
normalerweise nimmt man einfach den
inneren rand und er malt da jetzt mit
einem bleistift stimme den äußeren rand
und schneidern einfach ein bisschen
kleiner
fritz schneidig das einfache entlang der
ledige
dann kommt dieses herzchen ist einfach
in die backform rein
jetzt habe ich die backform schön
aufgelegt und bat noch ganz kurz auf die
eier machte die eier mache ich jetzt
richtig schön aufgeschlagen und ich gebe
da jetzt noch einmal extrakt dazu hat so
ein paar tropfen darf auch recht nicht
viel davon und auch - sal
und dann brauche ich die küchenmaschine
auch schon gar nicht mehr denn der rest
wird per hand einfach unterschiedlich
nicht mit der hand
jetzt nehme ich mir denn sie und gibt da
die trockenen zutaten rein einfach damit
sie keine klümpchen bilden also das mehl
die stärke und das backpulver
normalerweise wird beinahe wiener masse
eigentlich gar kein backpulver benutzt
aber ich mache trotzdem immer gern mit
rein weil oftmals passiert leuten dass
dann die macht ja nicht richtig aufgeht
und siegt aber meistens nur daran dass
die eier macht nicht richtig
aufgeschlagen wurde
aber ich finde ich mal einfach auf der
sicheren seite und man hatte man im
perfekten tag
kurz durch 7 und jetzt wird es mit der
hand also einem teig scharfer
untergehoben ganz vorsichtig immer von
außen nach innen einfach so praktisch
die mail masse unterstreichen
und wenn es dann so ungefähr komplett
verbunden ist kommt auch die flüssige
butter mittanzen
sie darf natürlich nicht mehr heiß sein
denn sonst gerinnt und sind die eier und
das wird jetzt auch noch kurz
untergehoben und man sieht auch schon
mir richtig schön locker der teig ist
und da wird auch später richtig schön
weich und hier ist es einfach wichtig
dass man nicht zu lange rührt oder unter
hebt deswegen höre ich jetzt auch auf
und füllt den trike direkt jetzt in die
springform oder in den agrar
und so darf der teig jetzt bei 175 grad
ober und unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei mir brauche ungefähr 35
minuten
falls ihr in mein herz springt form
wächst die ebenen boden hat mister
länger backen denn in so buck rahmen
backt man in der regel so um 20 kürzer
und ich würde sage ich dass hier eine
komplett abkühlen und sehen uns gleich
meinte packt jetzt noch ein bisschen ich
muss jetzt aber schon mal die
zwischenzeit um meine buttercreme
vorzubereiten
normalerweise mag ich hab übrigens nicht
so gerne vor allem nicht die deutsche
und die amerikanische buttercreme die
sind wir meistens einfach viel zu fettig
und viel zu süß aber ich möchte heute
eine leckere fruchtige buttercreme
machen
die hatte ich auch schon mal in eine
hochzeitstorte mit drin und die war
richtig lecker und ich zeige euch ganz
christi zutaten
ich brauche nämlich dafür etwas
fruchtsaft und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
erdbeeren dass man tiefgefrorene
erdbeeren die habe ich jetzt einfach
über nacht auftauen lassen und ihr seht
da ist ganz viel fruchtsaft ausgetreten
und den saft werde ich jetzt gleich
benutzen also ich gehe es gleich die
erdbeeren ab ihr könnt doch auch einfach
so und saft aus dem tetrapack zum
beispiel nehmen aber am besten einen der
nicht so säcke zucker ist eventuell
brauchen wir etwas zucker es kommt
einfach darauf an wie süß die erdbeeren
sind und wenn er den saft habt und
gezuckert ist braucht einfach keinen
zucker ich habe ca 60 km abgewogen
dann brauche ich 30 g speisestärke
eigelbe eine ps salz und später brauche
ich noch 210 gramm butter de ist zimmer
war das ist auch ganz wichtig die kann
ich jetzt aber mal zur seite stellen
denn ich brauche zuerst mal die zutaten
für ein pudding wenn die klassische
buttercreme die deutsche foto creme wird
aus einem pudding und butter gemacht und
ich werde jetzt aus diesen fruchtsaft
ebenen pudding herstellen und jetzt habe
ich hier einfach eine glasschüssel oder
ich kann auch eigentlich direkt dem topf
nehmen denn dann spar ich mir einmal die
schüssel zu spüren
ich wollte euch etwas zeigen aber das
mache ich jetzt einfach so und jetzt
habe ich dann eine vage darunter und
kann einfach die app wenn abgießen und
muss mir jetzt 330 milliliter abmessen
jetzt gehe ich da einfach mit einem
schneebesen oder mit einem löffel hin
und drück einfach immer wieder hier den
saft der erzfeind aus bis sich einfach
am ende 330 milliliter habe
das sieht jetzt ein fruchtsaft aus und
ich habe es natürlich hier ganz viele
reste etwa reste aber die schweiz jetzt
natürlich nicht weg die könnte jetzt zum
beispiel zu einem müsli mit dazu geben
oder einfach beim mixen und 1 movie
draus machen also schmeißt die nicht weg
ihr könnt ihr einfach weiter benutzen
oder auch einfach eine leckere
quarkcreme daraus machen zum beispiel
ich nehme jetzt etwas zucker ich nehme
jetzt aber nicht alles denn die
erdbeeren szene relativ süß und jetzt
kommen einfach alle zutaten rein also
auch speisestärke und dann werden wir
das gleich ganz kurz verrühren und
danach eben nur noch erhitzt werden das
noch mit rein und die prise salz muss
jetzt ein bisschen auskratzen damit
alles rein kommt
und jetzt habe ich hier einfach so eine
masse in der alles drinsteckt und muss
jetzt einfach mit einem schneebesen
schön glatt rühren damit sie einfach
keine klümpchen drin habe jetzt 11
monate dauern
und jetzt schalte ich hier einfach den
herd auf mittlerer stufe und wer das
jetzt einfach etwas erhitzen bis es am
auftaucht und ich mache es auf edle
rasse auf mittlerer stufe
weil einfache ich nicht möchte dass der
boden eben anbrennt und es kann ganz
schnell passieren weise produkten oder
bei so machen und deswegen bei mittlerer
hitze und es dauerte etwa fünf minuten
und zwar als aufgekocht ist kann ich den
herd ausschalten denn angst pudding
fertig und den fühle ich dann einfach
direkt um damit er schneller abkühlen
kann
und gibts einfach hier in die formen der
vorhin der saft drin war und durch das
eigelb und durch die stärke wie die
recruiting richtig schön gebunden kann
sich das hier noch runter und damit sich
da jetzt keine haut drauf bildet das
kennt man ja vom pudding so dass ich da
ab und zu eine haut bildet deswegen gebe
ich da jetzt einfach um das zu
verhindern imbiss mit frischhaltefolie
drüber einfach direkt auf den pudding
direkt an die oberfläche und so lasse
ich den pudding jetzt einfach bei
raumtemperatur abkühlen meinen
kuchenteig müsste jetzt auch gleich
fertig sein und ich freue mich hier ganz
kurz auf das hier können wir übrigens
noch stehen lassen also den sieg weil
das braucht man sowieso gleich wieder
von daher muss man sich auswaschen aber
alles andere mache sauber und dann sehen
wir uns nicht wieder
der pudding ist abgekühlt und die jetzt
kann ich meine mutter bremen vorbereiten
ich habe übrigens den kuchen einfach auf
einem küchentuch gestürzt und jetzt ist
er auch richtig kalt und den habe ich
jetzt bereits auf mit hübscher
tortenplatte gesetzt den lasse jetzt
einfach kurz hier stehen und bereitet
die creme zu und jetzt kann es natürlich
sein dass ihr in eurem pudding ein paar
klümpchen drin hab zum beispiel vom
eigelb oder von der speisestärke und
deswegen streich das jetzt einfach mal
durch ein sieb deswegen habe ich ihn
auch freundin sieht einfach aufgehoben
und der nicht gewaschen
es gebe ich das einfach zurück in die
schüssel und streicht es durch dann wird
die creme auch richtig schön locker und
vor allen dingen richtig schön zart und
weich und während ich das hier mache
kann ich in der gleichen zeit schon mal
die zimmer warme butter verrühren
die kann da einfach früheren etwa fünf
bis zehn minuten bist du schön weiß
schaumig ist oder weiß cremig besser
gesagt die wird dann auch schön luftig
und jetzt mache ich es einfach mal ganz
schnell
und wenn die mutter dann so aussieht als
es richtig schön weiß cremig schaut mal
richtig locker dann können wir jetzt
esslöffel weise einfach den pudding dazu
geben während dem rühren einfach auf
mittleren stufe
jetzt kann ich die buttercreme umfüllen
und ihr seht jetzt auch schon das eine
richtig schöne farbe hat als es ein
schönes leichtes rosé und die
buttercreme riecht richtig fruchtig also
hier nichts total nach erdbeer im haus
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt das jetzt zu
lassen
wer übrigens eine weiße creme lieber
machen möchte und weiße rosen stützen
möchte kann einfach zb wenig benutzten
oder auch kokosmilch also da kann auch
andere geschmacksrichtungen einfach mit
reinbringen
aber ich möchte jetzt dass meine creme
nicht so hellrosa bleibt sondern etwas
freundlicher wird und deswegen habe ich
mir jetzt hier noch lebensmittelfarben
zurechtgelegt einmal rosa und einmal rot
von deco wachsende gibt in jedem
supermarkt als in jedem gut sortierten
jetzt nehme ich einfach ein bisschen
farbe und gibt es hier mit rein
ich denke jetzt einfach nicht in rot ein
bisschen rosa dass ich so einen schönen
ton erhalte
und das rühre ich kurz mit dem teig
darunter kann ich jetzt natürlich auch
mit der küchenmaschine machen aber ich
wollte euch einfach das ganze in ein
glasgefäß zeigen
als ich da einfach wenn man schöne
angucken kann
und das sieht man jetzt schon wie die
creme sich verfärbt
ich habe die buttercreme jetzt kurz im
kühlschrank gestellt und werde mich
jetzt um den teig kümmern
ich habe jetzt gerade meine torte säge
nicht deswegen schlecht das ist einfach
mit einem messer aber einfacher geht's
natürlich mit einer tollen serie denn
dann hat man einfach gleichmäßige bösen
und ich schneid den boden jetzt einfach
in drei teile also schnell zweimal durch
und versuche das jetzt so gleichmäßig
wie möglich zu machen
jetzt nehme ich mit einem torten retter
die zwei böden runter und las praktisch
jetzt erst mal nur den boden darf
relativ gleichmäßig geschnitten und
jetzt nehme ich mir eine erdbeer
marmelade und zwar ist es eine ohne
stückchen und ohne kerne und die streite
ich jetzt einfach in die mitte einfach
das nicht innen drin noch so einen
fruchtigen geschmack und verstreicht es
mit einer winkel palette und es bringt
ja auch nochmal feuchtigkeit mit in den
teig man könnte jetzt auch die böden
tränken mit einem decoder mit einem
sirup oder um etwas anderes mit einem
saft dann setze ich einfach beide wieder
drauf und nehmen den oberen wieder weg
und da kommt jetzt auch noch marmelade
reihen
jetzt nehme ich mir meine creme und
streicht eine ganz dünne schicht auf den
kuchen einfach so als grundlage für die
rosen die wir gleich drauf spritzt das
verteile ich jetzt hier mit seiner
kleinen winkel palette am rand auch ein
bisschen
und die restliche creme fühle ich jetzt
in einen spritzbeutel und da habe ich
jetzt so einen einweg spritzbeutel neben
den adapter dafür für meine spritzt
hülle und ich benutze jetzt hier eine
stelle mit elf millimetern
also da musst du einfach darauf achten
dass ich eine stern schule ist denn so
können wir dann perfekte hosen spritzen
da schneide ich mir jetzt vorne und
bislang ab da kommt da die kühe drauf
und schlussendlich das ganze in meinen
spritzbeutel stellen so schnell habe
dann einfach die hände frei und kann die
creme 3 1 führen
ich mache das jetzt auch nicht sofort
den rest völlig gleich noch nach
denn sonst kann ich einfach nicht so
sauber arbeiten das rückseite jetzt
verschlägt es einfach durch
drehbewegungen und dann habe ich einfach
den perfekten druck da vorne und kann
hier praktisch die creme aussprechen
und jetzt kommen hier die rosen auf die
torte direkt drauf es gibt da einfach
verschiedene möglichkeiten wie man rosen
spritzen kann die eine möglichkeit ist
die hier das ist die einfache methode
und dann gibt es auch eine möglichkeit
mit einer anderen spritzt hülle einzelne
rosenblätter zu spritzen
aber das dauert einfach etwas länger und
deswegen zeige ich euch die einfache
variante
und jetzt setzt sich hier unten an
ziemlich mittig und spritzt hier einfach
die rosen
so zieht jetzt meine fertige torte aus
und jeweils auch noch mal etwa einer
stunde im kühlschrank und ich muss euch
dazu sagen die buttercreme die hatte mir
nicht gereicht
ich habe jetzt einfach noch mal die
gleiche portion buttercreme gemacht und
die oberseite damit bedeckt aber ihr
müsst wirklich drauf aufpassen einfach
die doppelte menge an buttercreme nehmen
aber ich schreibe das rezept ja sowieso
auf meinem blog jetzt schneidet die
torte an
so sieht sie sind inneren aus als mit
den drei teigschichten
ich finde auch auf dem teller sieht es
richtig hübsch aus vor allen dingen
könnte man ja noch zur deko einfach so
zwei drei großen blätter mit darzulegen
und wenn man dann noch eine saubere
garten neben legt sich richtig schön auf
ich kann es gar problem wirklich
aussieht
aber ich probiere butter krems ist man
übrigens am besten zimmer warm also so
ganz kalt ist man die gar nicht weil da
sich das aroma nicht so ganz entfalten
kann und deswegen lass es am besten so
etwa noch mal eine viertel stunde
draußen stehen bevor sie es aber ich
probiere es einfach direkt
cju
manche
ich möchte richtig noch etwa
und wer möchte kann natürlich auch innen
rein ein bisschen buttercreme streiten
aber ich bin sein fast schon zu viel
also soviel buttercreme könnte ich gar
nicht essen
ok murat hat auch geschmeckt und ich
hoffe natürlich dass euch dieses rezept
gefallen hat und dass ihr das einfach
mal nach macht ich bin die rosen zu
spritzen geht ja auch sehr einfach dass
ich eine sehr schnelle torte und vor
allen dingen ist natürlich nicht hübsche
torte das war auch was für die mama für
muttertag zum beispiel das rezept
schreibe ich wie gesagt auf meinem blog
blog de und ich wünsche euch noch ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen freue mich
über eure fotos und über eure kommentare
und wir raten rotznase die sich krank
bis zum nächsten mal